joining us here right now
is the creator of pro football talk mr
pro football talk himself and also he's
got a book called playmakers that's
coming out in mid-march where you can
pre-order it where all books can be
acquired right now he kicks everything
off on nbc sports on peacock every day
he is mike florio how are you mike i'm
doing great rich how are you today what
do you make of um i got to tell you i
learned about hub arcush's uh you know
thoughts on
not going to vote for aaron rodgers
through your site michael david smith
with a terrific post on it i agreed with
every word that he said i'll give you
the floor on it mike well have arkis was
on 670 to score just moments ago and
he's still on there right now and they
opened the segment asking him about the
firestorm and he said he made a mistake
but his regret comes from talking
publicly about his voting plans he at no
time
acknowledge that
his voting plan is substantively
erroneous and he should not be
considering off-season drama vaccination
pre-verification or anything else other
than performance on the field week one
through week 18. the fact that they
secured the number one seed his numbers
are phenomenal he continues to be one of
the best quarterbacks in the nfl
those are the things that should be
considered not whether or not he's the
biggest jerk in the league and i'm able
to compartmentalize the two i think he's
a phenomenal quarterback and i think
he's a gigantic jerk who loves attention
loves to make himself into the victim
when he's not the victim the woke mob
never came after him he's worried about
being canceled he's never going to be
canceled if anything he's more
not popular necessarily but more visible
than ever before
but as it relates to this it actually
helps him i think that arkis said what
he said because to the extent that there
are other voters that may have been
thinking
about not voting for him for reasons
other than football those voters may
think you know what
i i i don't want to do this and i don't
want to deal with the headache on the
back end if i don't vote for aaron
rodgers and i can't defend it and people
are going to think i didn't vote for
aaron rodgers because i think he's the
biggest jerk in the world well look man
it's most valuable player i mean it's
insane that anybody would hold whatever
rogers is doing
uh and saying
against him in terms of his on-field
play which is what this award is off the
field stuff there's the walter payton
manny of the year award that's what that
award's for and in many ways it is
rightfully
a bigger award than mvp award for some
uh it is the best picture
if you will of the nfl honors it hits
the final award you know
so uh for many reasons
that's what that's for
and
the mvp award is for most valuable
player and i would even understand that
you don't you can't make the most value
player with somebody who's been
suspended for weeks due to a violation
of conduct or a violation
of uh you know
uh steroids
like that that i can sort of you know
countenance this is absurd
this is absurd and the fact that he's
now saying i apologize for saying the
way i feel
is is a total
non-starter non-starter for me
well and here's the problem there's only
50 people who have these votes so he has
a two percent voice in all of the awards
that are made part of the nfl honors
they are the official nfl awards mvp
comeback player your coach of the year
offensive and defensive rookie of the
year offensive and defensive player of
the year and the all-pro team and when
you admit that you are considering
improper factors as to one where else
are you
considering improper factors i think
they should take him off the panel they
have time to do it the votes haven't
been cast yet they won't be cast until
next week they should take him off the
panel and they should replace him i
think that's a no-brainer and i asked
the league for comment on it because
it's the official nfl awards and they
say it's not appropriate for us to
comment well why wouldn't it be why
wouldn't it be you're tying the shield
to these awards and if there are
fundamental problems with the voting
process that's something the league
should be concerned about and i hope
behind the scenes even though the league
won't say anything publicly they don't
want to call out the ap yada yada
hopefully somebody from 345 park avenue
contacted somebody from the ap today and
said we can't have this we just can't
have this mindset infecting these awards
because they are
important and
it's a big deal and especially for all
pro voting you've got major contract
incentives that can be tied to those
awards mike florio here on the rich
eisen show uh from pro football talk why
is antonio brown still on the bucks
if he is no longer a buck
mike well i'm a big believer in occam's
razor a complicated concept that relies
on the notion that the simplest
explanation for anything is usually the
true explanation and the simplest
explanation for this is the buccaneers
want to not have their cake and not have
anyone else eat it too they don't want
him playing for them
and they don't want him playing for
anyone else and i think the core is this
neither bruce arians nor jason light nor
anyone else with the organization wants
to have to be the one who explains to
tom brady
why
antonio brown was able to catch 10
passes and gain 152 yards and score two
touchdowns in super bowl 56 for the
chiefs and contribute to the victory
over the buccaneers i mean that's the
bottom line and i don't know that the
chiefs would sign him but you know what
they gave josh gordon his umpteenth
second chance earlier this year and
gordon has five catches for 32 yards in
11 games antonio brown can do that in
his sleep 10 days ago he had 10 catches
for 101 yards after not playing for 10
weeks so
i think they just don't want him to land
somewhere else they're trying to come up
with a way i believe
to put him on ice for the rest of the
season so that they don't have to worry
about antonio brown landing with and the
three teams i'd i'd watch and and there
are people in the league who say no way
know how he doesn't get another chance i
think he's come back from worse than
this and talent always finds a way
chiefs packers and rams are the three
teams i've watched
i i would i would now i don't know if
the packers would do it i think the
chiefs would be more likely to do it and
the rams we just know any big name that
lingers long enough somebody in the
organization decides we must add him to
the collection
like they did with obj
yeah i i i just
you know
it it's kind of crazy uh literally and
and i figuratively but i also think
literally um i i do think that that
something has to be a foot with with
antonio brown
uh between his temples that needs to be
addressed you know who who is in his
corner like who is team antonio who's
the one who helped him get that uber you
know who's the one who got him the nets
tickets right like and who's the one who
is fighting for his grievance is it drew
rosenhouse still
rosenhouse fired him a couple of years
ago when he refused to get help at a
time when he clearly was going through
issues that required some sort of
intervention to the point where he
wouldn't listen to anyone and his agent
now is ed wazileski and i've texted ed
several times this week and haven't
gotten a response and it's entirely
possible that antonio brown right now
isn't listening to anyone and isn't
cooperating with anything and that makes
it hard you know he has rights and i i'm
not defending antonio brown but i think
the challenge is if you respect the
fundamental rights that everyone has the
hardest
and most challenging and trying time
to respect those rights is at a time
when the person's popularity is as low
as it can be and i think that's when
it's even more important to remember
that he does have rights that it's not
fair for the buccaneers to manipulate
the process to try to keep him from
potentially landing with another team
but at some point
he's got to help himself for example
he's still on the team even though bruce
arians told the world on monday he's or
sunday rather he's off the team
well he didn't show up for practice
today so unless there's some sort of an
agreement behind the scenes that he's
excused i'd have been there hey you
haven't cut me i'm on the team i'm
coming to practice deal with me and you
know they may be able now if he doesn't
show up and he didn't have
an excuse to not show up put him on the
left squad list shut him down for the
rest of the year they get to where they
want to be i just really think their
goal is to get to a point where he can't
play for anyone else and it's unclear
what he or anyone close to him is doing
to ensure that he can still play this
year if he even wants to he may not want
to he may be in a mindset right now
where he's done with the nfl short term
and possibly long term but the nfl
is never fully done with someone who has
proven talent we've seen it time and
again with him
and with others your talent is always
going to get you
another chance and another chance and
another chance because fundamentally and
ultimately there are people out there
who want to win and the super bowl ring
lasts a hell of a lot longer than the
short-term dysfunction that you have to
fight through did you suggest antonio
brown chipola costanza is that what
you're saying
because he was fired right right well i
mean it wasn't ant
didn't antonio brown apparently get
fired on the sideline right well he got
fired on the sideline but i think the
buccaneers are trying to do the reverse
costanza where they fired him one day
and the next day they're acting like he
wasn't fired so it's the opposite
of the costanza move of quitting and
then showing up the following monday
and acting like none of it had ever
happened so the bucks are the ones doing
because they fired him that's why he
stormed off i mean hey look if someone
came to me if i happen to still work in
an office and i thank god every day that
i don't
and somebody came to me after lunch and
said you're fired i'm not
waiting until five to walk out i'm
leaving the moment they tell me i'm
fired yeah but are you are you taking
off your shirt and and throwing all
everything in this you know uh i'm
serious like into other cubicles if i
had antonio brown's physique maybe i
would
i mean because
without his physique no and that's the
thing too that's fine antonio zeke i'd
never put a shirt on and and just to you
know i guess ground this conversation
back a little bit more in reality after
i personally took it out of it um the
the the concept that another team
would take him
when
antonio brown
not once
but twice
twice has left tom brady twice right
now the first time was when the sports
illustrated article came out and he's in
new england and he thought new england
didn't have his back and then he trashes
robert craft which is the end of that
and then gets another opportunity to
play with tom brady wins a ring with him
and has an opportunity to do it again
now
and regardless of what happened on the
sideline
twice now why would anybody what better
situation is there for a wide receiver
in the history potentially of the
national football league well why he
would want to not be with tom brady or
do anything that would jeopardize his
ability with tom brady to be with tom
brady is a different question of whether
or not some other great quarterback out
there would look at him and say this guy
can help me make the difference patrick
mahomes could say hey this guy can help
me make the difference because i've been
waiting for someone to rise up across
from tyreek hill and at times we think
it's going to be byron pringle or
demarcus robinson or josh gordon and
nobody's getting it done i don't have a
sami watkins i need a sami watkins if i
want to win a super bowl and maybe he
can be my sami watkins so i think that's
a big part of it and rich the reason
that i think the buccaneers fear that he
will find another
home even after what we saw on sunday
think back to 2019 the month of august
all the dysfunction that he created with
the raiders starting with the frozen
feet
continuing with the helmet that he was
no longer allowed to wear because it was
no longer certified by the nfl and he
made a big to-do about that he got into
it with mike mayok allegedly said some
racially inappropriate things to mike
mayok eventually was begging to get cut
got cut the same day
after all that crap and everything that
proceeded in the off season as he
tweeted his way out of pittsburgh the
day he got cut by the raiders bill
belichick swoops in
so
that's what makes me think
andy reid who just found out that even
though his team won eight games in a row
they got some flaws on both sides of the
ball they didn't adjust the way they
needed to offensively to the bengals
defense they didn't adjust the way they
needed to defensively the bengals
offense and they had their eight-game
winning streak come to an end and now
single elimination time is looming and i
i think that's why i believe
this will be forgotten especially if and
when brown wants to play and if brown is
able to sit down and explain himself why
he did what he did andy reid is the king
of giving guys second chances and and
and that's fine that's his prerogative
but that's why i think
that you know as we get farther away
from the spectacle on sunday we just
need to keep in mind that
people are trying to win super bowls
here and they're willing to deal with a
lot of things if they have a guy who
they can put out on the field who's
going to help them get to where they're
trying to go last one for you mr uh
florio mike florio here on the rich
eisen show one week from today let's uh
let's smash cut uh one of my favorite uh
uh cliches in the nfl is i don't have a
crystal ball none of us do
but
one week from today the vacancies in the
nfl are what on the head coaching front
well the two easy ones are the jaguars
and the raiders now beyond that here's
where i'm watching because what's what's
interesting to me is there's been no
public or as far as anyone can tell
private assurance is given
by any of the owners to any of the
coaches that i'm watching i'm watching
that rule with the panthers mike zimmer
with the vikings matt maggie with the
bears and pete carroll with the seahawks
also i'll throw in vic fangio with the
broncos though i think the looming sale
of the team which is expected next year
could get him one more year because why
tie the hands of a new owner with a new
coach that you're paying 10 million
dollars a year to or whatever the number
is going to be but those five are the
ones i'm really watching
and you know history tells us that
roughly half of the ones that we think
are gonna hit end up being vacant
they'll be six or seven by the time it's
all said and done and then there's gonna
be some curveball something we're not
expecting and i think a couple of years
ago
nothing unexpected was the unexpected
outcome because we were so conditioned
to expect a surprise last year doug
peterson kind of the delayed reaction
firing by the eagles that was a surprise
so you know i i don't want to speculate
on where the surprise may come from but
i i say that we're gonna have
let's say we're gonna have five next
week and we're gonna be waiting for the
surprise and my best guess is
zimmer's out
nagi's out
and
if i had to pick one more
i'd lean fangio but i'm really watching
matt rule because i think david tepper
is determined to get himself a high-end
coach and with jim harbaugh sniffing
around about a possible return to the
nfl if that's not just leverage to get
more money out of michigan right
uh you could do a hell of a lot worse
than jim harbaugh considering he was 44
19 and one in four years with the 49ers
and there are some rule defenders who
say well no one comes from college and
turns a team around in two years no
harbaugh turned it around in one year he
went from six and ten to the brink of
the super bowl and then the next year he
was at the brink of a super bowl
championship and it's amazing we forget
that because he's been gone for a while
now but
uh he's shown he can get it done
and and if he's in play
uh that's that's probably gonna result
in more not fewer vacancies well a
reason why
we've forgotten about it i'll um you
know i mean
i can i can actually put my finger on it
it's because of of harbaugh's inability
to beat a guy who came to the nfl and
flamed out in the worst triple lindy
flop in the history of coaching
you know that's that's that's basically
the i'm spitting truth right there i
think mike so don't forget
at this level and look rich with jim
harbaugh you know uh there's a great
quote in a gary myers book about coaches
and sons and there's a chapter about
jack harbaugh and jim and john harbaugh
and when jack harbaugh was coaching and
the harbaugh boys were growing up you
know they're moving every few years uh
at one point jim came to his dad and
said well it's time to move i lost my
last friend and he's got a habit of
wearing people out and i'm surprised
he's lasted at michigan as long as he
has because he'd been on the four-year
plan everywhere else that after four
years it's time he's got to go we can't
take him anymore so that's another thing
to consider if you bring him back to the
nfl there's a chance that the candle
burns really bright and it doesn't burn
for very long
but again there are teams out there that
have been doing a lot worse than what
harbaugh did with the 49ers well and
just let's just linger here just one
last bit here i think if jim does do
this though he's going to want to go to
a spot where there's a quarterback right
where he where he knows
that guy is there and the question is is
carolina that spot i don't think so uh
the raiders have that spot clearly uh
with derek carr if he feels that derek
is the guy
uh does he want to hook up with uh you
know
ryan day's portal transfer in chicago
you know like does he want to do that uh
or does he want to
um see if denver you know join them um
you know and and see if that is an
opportunity i don't know where else
there would be and i guess that also
leads me to the last question too is
what about joe judge what a bizarre
soliloquy he had after getting waxed by
chicago about players who used to be on
the team are still calling to see
you know uh if they can come back on
um and then some strange thing about
2018 that they thought he was going to
lose his job and they still made the
super bowl and the patriots were seven
and two mid-season like i don't know if
belichick makes his assistants think
they were all going to lose their jobs i
it was weird it was weird it tells me
this is a guy who even though it's
reported that he's coming back has not
gotten the level of confidence that he
needs otherwise he wouldn't have felt
compelled to go off like he did and
it really was bizarre he basically
admitted to tampering which uh you know
the nfl rarely enforces that rule
because it doesn't like to but sometimes
it's so obvious you can't not
enforce it but that was strange one last
point on harbaugh though you got my mind
uh racing on this because when he went
to san francisco he had alex smith right
and he drafted a guy in the second round
that's perfect remember who he drafted
yeah kaepernick yeah
and he has been i interviewed him 2017
year one of the kaepernick free agency
that is still ongoing five years later
uh he was very very very big on
kaepernick then and uh and i've said all
along the only way he's ever getting
back in is if jim harbaugh comes back to
the nfl now maybe it's too long you know
the fact that they've successfully
kicked the can for five years and kept
him out for five years may make it
impractical
but
the only guy who was ever going to bring
harbaugh or kaepernick back to the nfl
may be coming back to the nfl and that's
that's just an angle to keep an eye on
uh depending upon where he ends up if he
does make the jump and isn't just trying
to get you know huge money out of
michigan he's got every right to try to
do it he may just be working all angles
to get maximum money god love him
capitalist society go get yours mike
florio pro football talk again uh what
when is um when is your book coming out
play march 15. okay very good r15 you
see you know what angst that that's
causing me you're starting to troll me
now like you're super here i'm not
you're doing it with a smile on your
face you're jabbing a knife into my ribs
i'm sure you're not excited your book's
coming out i'm not excited why not
because it is
it is a source of stress for me because
are people going to like it are they
going to say bad things about it
am i going to be trending on twitter for
some stupid i wrote in chapter 28. is no
one going to buy it i you know i'm
really having regrets how about this
mike how about this mike may your book
trend on twitter you should go to sleep
every night playing praying to that god
that's true i mean so and and then your
name is spelled right and the tough
again
my book the tough
i found out firsthand what everyone was
telling me the toughest part about
writing a book is selling it
so that's common and but it'll be great
you're terrific at these uh you know
chats and you'll have a blast yeah so
well i appreciate you and uh i've
already accepted the fact that it's
going to be a colossal failure because
everywhere it goes it's going to be a
win
see that's the costanza you're doing the
opposite i like it i like it take care
of mike thanks you guys mike floor
everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here